quand vous dites vous allez chercher
monsieur cifaoui dans le vous
qui le dit pardon d'accord il dit que le
cabinet l'a appelé la joie vérifiera
sincèrement qui nous confirme les choses
dont le vous et je vous le disais dès le
début de l'audition et si les consignes
que j'avais passé dans ces rencontres
auditions avec les uns les autres pour
alimenter la réflexion collective je
souhaitais que les acteurs soient reçus
conjointement par le cabinet par
l'administration il n'y a pas de
dichotomie les choses se font ensemble
donc le vous est un vous qui est très
collectif
et quand vous dites c'est pas ce que
nous dit Monsieur Gravel
monsieur Gravel nous dit c'est pas vous
collectif monsieur Gravel nous dit
Monsieur Sifaoui nous a appelé pour nous
dire qu'il rentrait sur le fond Marianne
qu'il avait vu la ministre qu'il avait
croisé le cabinet on verra avec lui
mais il nous dit bien que ce projet lui
est arrivé il est pas arrivé par le
cabinet qui en discute avec lui il est
arrivé par Monsieur Sifa oui c'est pour
ça que je me permets je crois que la
Formation Judiciaire
déterminera la façon le jeu se sont
passées véritablement et précisément moi
ce que je la connais pas monsieur le
Président c'est que la consigne que
j'avais passée c'est que les acteurs
soient reçus conjointement par le
cabinet par l'administration sont qui
est de dichotomie entre les uns les
autres
et le projet qui est présenté par l'uepn
n'est pas un projet que le cabinet et
moi-même sommes allés chercher nous
l'avons réceptionné ce dossier il est
arrivé d'ailleurs au cipdr
le point est important